your whole life
you pushed yourself to be faster than
don
smarter than dom
do you hate him enough it keeps you up
at night
[Music]
to be able to work with charlize and
bring cypher money well spent she just
brings not only the sense of
professionalism but her level of
awareness when she showed up she could
tell we were still fresh and we were
still having a great time and she was
able to feed off that energy what's so
fun about writing for a character like
cypher is she just knows exactly where
to stick the knife and how to twist i
bet all you ever wanted was a hug you
read my psyche val
good for you charlize is not as good as
you all think she is she's far better
than that i was just looking at her in
amazement of what she does and how good
she is this would be the moment where
the villain has an unexpected setback
charlie's theron is just extremely
precise meticulous she keeps on working
with it keeps on seeing new nuances of
it and it's such an inspiration to me i
think actually she frightened john into
it you know i look at her and i feel
creeped out
and sort of turned on at the same time
she is one step ahead of everybody i
think john felt that
he definitely seemed shook adding your
brother dawn to the mix
you